if you want to win with money let me
give you a good idea figure out what
most people are doing and run in the
other direction run in the other
direction
most people are broke
most people look good and they're broke
they spend more than they have coming in
they don't act their wage they don't
live on a plan they don't agree on
spending with their spouse their only
hope for retirement is that the
government which is well known for its
ability to handle money will take care
of them they don't have money set aside
for emergencies
they run credit card debt and student
loans and card debt all day every day
they spend like they're in Congress most
people are stupid when it comes to money
70% of Americans are living paycheck to
paycheck the bankruptcy rate is at an
all-time high foreclosures are rising
again credit card debt continues to
climb and we have a trillion dollars in
student loan debt out there the average
car payment America today now is four
hundred and ninety six dollars over
eighty four months that's stupid
normal in America is broke and stupid
you don't want to be normal you want to
be weird one of the greatest compliment
you can get on this shows if you call up
and say man you're weird I'm looking at
weird people you guys are weird which
means that you're contrary you are a
contrarian you're perpendicular to the
culture when the culture has lost its
way the best thing you can do is be
opposite figure out whatever they're
doing and do the other thing right
because you're not gonna get you're only
going to get what they're getting when
you do what they're doing this is not
hard to figure out if you keep doing
what you've been doing you're gonna keep
getting what you've been getting you do
reap what you sow you live in a cause a
cause and of
to world baby there's no way around this
so you're going when I went broke I
realize my goal is to be weird my goal
is to be different in personal finances
80-percent behavior it's only 20% head
knowledge so this is not some math
formula that you've got a problem with
this is a person in your mirror I
figured out if I can make the guy in my
mirror behave he can be skinny and rich
he's got issues and once we realize that
behavior is what causes people to handle
their money poorly or handle it well
then what we've got to decide is our
behaviors and if you have the same
behaviors as broke people have in when
it comes to money you're gonna have the
same back you're gonna have the same
results broke people if you're just
gonna be another broke person and some
of you are making $250,000 a year and
you're broke
yeah no money at all you got a mess
loans coming out your ears you can't
breathe you run run run run run run run
like a rat in a wheel have a heart
attack and I wonder what happened this
is no way to live
buying things you can't afford with
money you don't have to impress people
you don't really like something you
spent an unbelievable amount of money on
a car payment to impress somebody to
stop like you will never be introduced
to the buddy you felt cool there for
about what three and a half seconds fool
I've been that fool I know who he is
I've been that guy I've been that
shallow where I thought that my car
actually mattered to somebody get me a
break nobody gives a rip about your car
it listen if you know what I drive right
now anything I want you know why because
I drove crap for a long time I drove
cars like nobody else would drive now I
get to drive whatever I want to drive
and I don't drive them for you I Drive
them because I like them I couldn't give
a care less what you think about what I
drive it's not my problem it's not your
problem either by the way I'm gonna
enjoy I'm a boy
I like nice cars I'm gonna get them but
I'm not gonna have a nice car with a
stupid car payment on it it's ridiculous
if your self-esteem is so screwed up
that you're doing that then you're going
to struggle with money you're normal
people spending a bunch of money to act
like there's something they're not what
they call in Texas big hat no cattle you
need to decide I don't care what other
people think and I'm gonna be weird
whatever you're doing with money I'm
going to do the opposite thing and when
you decide that you'll start winning
with money I don't have any credit cards
not a single one no I don't believe in
points I've never met a millionaire so
they've you know made all my money with
my airline miles
no stupid people don't say that in the
real world I meet middle-class people
who spend everything on a credit card
because they're racking up points not
figure this math out for me you get 1%
back on your stupid Discover card right
have you ever discovered what the math
is on that Discover card that means if
you spend $100,000 you get $1,000 is
this a path to wealth anywhere you went
to math class that's just straight-up
stupid I mean in the sixth grade you
should have been able to figure the 4th
grade grade you should have been able to
figure that one out
that that's not gonna work I mean you
run a hundred grand through a stupid
credit card to get a free airline ticket
give me a break
with what you overspent you could have
bought ten airline tickets and all in
the name I'm racking up points I'm
beating you're not beating anybody
they're a multi-billion dollar company
they've got done so many behavior
studies on you based on your zip code
and your demographic they know what kind
of bottled water you drink fool they're
tracking you every movement you make on
the web is being followed with web
analytics they know exactly what you're
doing no this is not a conspiracy theory
they are better at marketing than you
are at living your life and they're
selling you so much crap you're broke
and you're playing their game
you're playing city bank's game what's
in your wallet I'll tell you what's in
my wallet money it's what's in my wallet
it's not a bunch of stupid plastic so
I'm weird Dave you're weird you're right
I'm not broke almost broke I don't want
to be normal I engage in weird
activities and so I get weird results
and that's called money I'm not broke
any more because I do things that broke
people don't do and I don't do things
that the broke people do do why is this
hard you want to be skinny find out what
skinny people eat eat what they eat
you'll be skinny you want to be fat eat
what fat people you will be fat this is
not rocket science people figure it out
you want to but you want a great
marriage well don't ask somebody's been
divorced six times we'll pray for them
but I don't need their marriage advice
they can't got this thing figured out
baby I want to find somebody that's
winning and emulate them this is not
rocket science be weird that's your goal
darling the weird weird weird weird
weird don't be normal this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]